Speaker 1: There were some genuinely
concerning news items yesterday related
to the elections and one of them came out of
Ron DeSantis is Florida as well as Missouri,
Washington Post reports. Florida, Missouri tell
Justice Department voting monitors to stay outside
of polling places. Federal monitors would need
local permission to observe activity inside
election sites. The administration of Governor Ron
DeSantis has refused to allow Justice Department
election monitors to go inside polling locations
in South Florida, saying in a letter it would
be counterproductive and potentially undermine
confidence in the election. Monday, the Justice
Department had announced it would send monitors to
64 jurisdictions nationwide, up from 44 in 2020,
to evaluate how are elections being conducted amid
a wave of threats to workers working at elections,
politicians and allegations of voter intimidation.
Miami Dade, Broward and Palm Beach counties
were slated to receive the Justice Department's
Civil Rights Division monitors. Florida federal
monitors were sent to some Florida localities
in 2020, but they stayed outside because of the
pandemic. Brad McVay, the chief counsel for the
Florida Department of State, said in a letter
those monitors will not be allowed inside polling
places under Florida law. McVay said the Florida
secretary of state's office, overseen by DeSantis,
would instead send its own monitors right.
DeSantis is on the ballot. It's totally logical
to send DeSantis his own monitors to make sure
everything is on the up and up. That makes
sense, right? That makes a lot of sense. Now,
there is a debate here as to whether DeSantis
has the authority to stop the monitoring. And
what The Washington Post article says is while the
Justice Department is permitted to place monitors
inside polling locations, the department must
receive permission from local election officials.
The Justice Department has said it
followed standard procedure on Tuesday,
has monitors outside polling locations in Florida
and Missouri, where state officials said they
would not be welcomed inside. This is not some big
smoking gun. It's just another example of how the
right is all about. We need monitors, we need
observers, we need this, that. The other thing,
we will train you to become such an individual.
Oh, the DOJ wants to send. Oh, now that would be
counterproductive to have them inside. I thought
more monitoring is good and it's just another
little data point about how their principles
are worthless. Monitoring elections is good
if it's their monitors, if it's their
organizations, but if it's the DOJ,
all of a sudden we don't need that. It would be
obtrusive. It would be counterproductive. Not a
surprise that as soon as it's inconvenient,
they abandon their so-called principles.